Thank you very much.
Now, I've got a story for you.
When I arrived off the plane,
after a very long journey from the West of England,
my computer, my beloved laptop,
had gone mad,
and had -- oh! -- a bit like that! --
and the display on it --
anyway, the whole thing had burst.
And I went to the IT guys here
and a gentleman mended my computer,
and then he said, "What are you doing here?"
and I said "I'm playing the cello and I'm doing a bit of singing,"
and he said, "Oh, I sort of play the cello as well."
And I said, "Do you really?"
Anyway, so you're in for a treat,
because he's fantastic, and his name's Mark.
(Applause)
I am also joined by my partner in crime, Thomas Dolby.
This song is called "Farther than the Sun."
(Music)